With this last part in place, the world's largest concrete boom pump...
...is ready for a long journey to Japan.
Made by the German firm, Putzmeister, this pump is normally used to carry concrete...
...in large construction projects.
But in Japan, it will have a very different purpose.
It's gonna be pumping fresh water to the cooling ponds to start.
Putzmeister Manager Gary Schmidt says, smaller pumps have already been spraying water...
...onto the damaged reactors to keep them from overheating.
But a giant pump like this with a 70 - meter vertical reach...
...or 25 stories high, can spray 160,000 liters of water every hour.
It can also do what the other pumps cannot.
It helps to get over any obstructions and in.
So, it will reach up and then back into the building.
Engineering Professor Ivan Catton says, having a bigger pump with a longer reach...
...will be more accurate than existing pumps at the reactors.
Two of these giant pumps from the US will be helping the Japanese government...
...to cool down the reactors at the earthquake and tsunami damaged Fukushima nuclear plant.
In the meantime, Catton says, the best hope for the Fukushima nuclear disaster...
...is to keep pouring water onto the reactors,...
...find and repair the problems, and wait for the situation to improve.
Elizabeth Lee for VOA News Los Angeles.